which countries at the moment have got
the worst demographics which countries
yeah which countries should be very
concerned about the ratio of young to
old
uh the worst in the world is China
they've been in the process of updating
their data over the course of the last
couple years and they're now starting to
publicly admit that they overcounted by
100 million people
all of those people would have been born
since one child so age 40 and under the
young worker demographic the child
bearing demographic and two-thirds of
them are probably women
so we best guess is that China only has
1.3 billion people now
the population probably peaked more than
10 years ago and by 2030 there will be
more retirees than workers and by 2050
the entire population of China will have
dropped below 650 million
that's wild it's beyond terminal yeah so
the Chinese system collapses this decade
for sure
assuming nothing else goes wrong and
there's plenty other competitors to put
the bullet in China's head
dude that is crazy okay so
yeah all the way from pre-industrial to
post-industrial collapse in 45 years
but I
just for the people that don't
understand about how the one child
policy and the preference for boys over
girls and stuff created this landscape
what's the what's the high level view of
that sure well there's two things
um first of all of course there's one
child Matt was concerned that they had a
young upcoming generation after World
War II that was going to eat the country
alive uh so they went to a two-child
policy ultimately to a one-child policy
and that was not loosened until 2015 but
by that point the damage was already
done because there was a second Factor
uh remember countries that industrialize
later can follow the path of those who
came before they can skip some steps so
China was the fastest ever
industrialization experience
uh what the United Kingdom did in Seven
Generations the Chinese did in one and
so they crammed seven generations of
economic growth and development into one
and that's why their growth rate has
been so impressive but you can only do
that once and now it's behind them
and now they have no children and they
have very few people under age 45.
is this
population growth and collapse similar
to an unknown number in a way that more
people allow you to have more children
which gives you more people to have more
children but if the reverse is happening
then it causes a nosedive
uh you're absolutely right there now I
don't want to say that um unchecked
population growth is necessarily the way
to go that's not what I'm after here I
mean you require a balance between
children young workers and mature
workers if you don't have enough mature
workers you don't have the capital you
don't have enough young workers you
don't have the consumption if you don't
have the children you don't have a
future
China is already out of that those last
two categories and so we know where this
leads it leads to zero
given the fact that humans are being I
think it's every three generations lives
for another generation at the moment
around about every generation lives
eight years younger longer than the
generation before increased Healthcare
Health span better access to that is
only true in the shift from
pre-industrial to Industrial so you get
that once
uh well it depends upon how you apply
the lessons to your system in the case
of Europe I'd say they got it three
times but there's definitely an upper
limit one of the the things to keep in
mind especially when you're talking
about European demographics is that
Europe in Europe people are not living
longer overall lifespan has not improved
what's improved is we've gotten rid of a
lot of mortality so the things that used
to kill you when you were 0 to 65 don't
kill you anymore
right okay that is going to change the
shape of demographics as well right the
fact that young people are able to get
old more easily say more safely more
safely yeah precisely so I guess there's
just a lot over the last hundred years
we've seen such change it's not just
being technological change but
Downstream from that is what's happened
demographically and how that's how
that's influenced the demography okay so
if medicine electricity sewage yeah if
China's got the worst who what are some
of the areas that have got better
looking demography uh the three
countries in the world in the in the
advanced World actually in the advanced
and in the developing world
um New Zealand France United States
uh and largely for the same reason uh
they're countries that have a little bit
more physical space
so their cities tend to be more of a
sprawl you're more likely to have a
backyard more people can live in the
countryside and be economically viable
so when these three countries urbanized
they did it at a slower rate and they
remained the three Advanced countries
with the lowest urbanization rates in
the world in the advanced developing
world the closest one was is going to be
Mexico and for similar reasons
um
um Central Mexico which is on a Highland
massive is just one giant suburban
sprawl and that means that people can
have more children now all of these
countries still have their own
demographic hiccups they all have the
baby boomer problem it's just that they
all have replacement Generations
I saw I had a conversation with Jordan
Peterson about this at the start of the
year and I did some research before is
the country with the highest
current birth rate per family Chad it
could be somewhere in Africa I'm gonna
guess probably somewhere in central
Africa yeah Chad Nigeria that that
cluster uh-huh but I'm gonna guess that
just lots of children isn't necessarily
a good answer either because you then
lock yourself into potential Futures you
can't birth any more or fewer
five-year-olds now it's whatever happens
this year is an hour ago yeah you get
precisely precisely precise so in the
case of sub-Saharan Africa and you know
this is a very broad array of countries
it's very difficult to make a
generalization
they've started to industrialize and so
they're going down the same path that
everybody else did and the first step of
that path is lowering infant and child
mortality and so when one out of three
children don't die
you have an explosion in your birth rate
but if you play that forward 10 15 years
then you start having adjustments in
Family Planning and you get smaller and
smaller families as urbanization kicks
in the danger for countries that are in
this category who've taken the first but
not the second step
is that they've imported a lot of the
Technologies of industrialization which
has helped them out but they have not
developed the systems to sustain that
themselves
so if something happens to the outside
environment they lose all of the
benefits well like
Health Care medicines fertilizers it's
very easy for me to see a lot of these
countries facing famine in the not too
distant future because if you break down
globalization you know yes that means
it's difficult to get oil or
manufactured goods I'm more concerned
about agriculture
agriculture is by far the most delicate
and vulnerable of the economic sectors
because it needs the equipment it needs
the finance it needs the fertilizers it
needs the trade options you break any of
those the whole system falls apart
uh and with the Ukraine war we are
seeing massive disruptions to the
fertilizer sector with some of the
decisions the Chinese have made same
thing so we're already looking this year
at losing
roughly a third of global fertile like
fertilizer Supply that is going to haunt
us for a decade
wow okay so for the people that maybe
haven't been able to work out why it is
that increasing urbanization and
education and development causes a
reduction in birth rate can you just
explain that first sure it's a wide
array of factors so when you move into a
city you have less room and that just
changes the mechanics of raising kids uh
when you move off the farm kids are no
longer Free Labor you have fewer of them
when you urbanize when you have
electricity you've generated time and so
people can do things after sunset this
is important for everything in terms of
economic development but it's most
important for women because if a woman
moves off the farm into the City and all
of a sudden can do something after hours
you have the opportunity for Mass
education and freeing them from doing
more than just being mothers nothing
wrong with being a mother but it's a
full-time job on the farm in the city
you're going to have fewer kids that's
less time allotted and you have a
greater chance to you know read and so
the entire women's right movement is
basically linked indelibly to
electricity
and once you have it women have fewer
kids because they now have other things
going on in their lives that compete for
attention they can go and get jobs they
can pursue careers they can do research
yes interesting we absolutely I mean the
the British example with the uh the
cotton Mills was probably the best
example the first group of people to
urbanize weren't the men it was the
women and we saw the impact on birthday
grades
going back to what you said there about
food shortages and the delicacy of
Agriculture I'm seeing a lot of videos
uh come out shaky phone videos come out
of China at the moment just how bad is
there any uh reliable information about
how bad food and the future of food will
be in China it's getting difficult to
get good information out of China it's
really demand devolved into a cult of
personality State even stricter than
what uh Mao Zedong had uh I don't think
that the Chinese having a food crisis
that is impacting their ability to have
calories at the moment
um Chinese land is among the worst in
the world and so it requires a huge
amount of fertilizer to grow anything
specifically phosphate for Rice by far
the world's most phosphate hungry crop
in the Chinese traditionally because of
that have been the world's largest
producer and exporter of the stuff the
problem is actually with African swine
fever now you may have heard of that a
few years ago they had a big outbreak
they ended up Colleen Mueller Hogs from
their farms and the rest of the world's
commercial Farms have Hogs
just give you an idea of just how
lopsided the pork Market is it's
two-thirds of it is China
they went to rebuild their herds but
they never abrogated the debts for the
farmers who went out of business they
just offered subsidies to bring in new
people they thought that would be
cheaper
well you have now two million new hog
farmers in China who have no idea what
they're doing and let's just say that uh
phyto sanitary does not translate into
Mandarin well in the first place so
we're probably in the early stages of a
second wave of ASF that'll probably be
just as bad if not worse than the first
one so pork just like it did two three
years ago is about to fall off the
market in China completely
that just leaves rice
so the Chinese have banned the export of
phosphate fertilizer in the short term
this is causing massive problems in
agricultural producers in east and south
Asia Australia especially Western
Australia is probably the part that's
getting gotten hit the hardest Brazil is
feeling the impacts these are Western
Australia and Brazil basically can't
grow without fertilizer they don't have
soil in the way that we think of the
term it's a weird geology
um
but
you interrupt the input flows
and it's very difficult to grow food at
volume and China in the best of times is
on a Razor's Edge in terms of food
sustainability and they use about three
to six times as much fertilizer as is
used in the global average just because
their land is so poor
uh
luckily phosphate they've got covered
they produce that themselves but the
nitrogen is all made with imported
Natural Gas
and the uh the phosphate half of I'm
sorry the potash half of that comes from
a different continent
so yeah China demographic collapse
unavoidable
food collapse highly likely
and that's before you start talking
about things like energy manufacturing
and trade does this not make China
unbelievably dangerous
the question is what would you do if
you're China where would you go to get
what you want
if you go into Kazakhstan fine but you
know what does the winner get
you can't go to India Himalaya is on the
way you could go into Vietnam but when
the Vietnamese when the I'm sorry when
the Chinese did that last in 1979 they
got treated just as well as the
Americans were and so that was a quick
War they don't have the Navy to push out
Japan and Taiwan could go nuclear in a
month hang on that just leaves Russia we
had this
China are taking over the South China
Sea there's all of these small island
debts that they're putting together
they've got this scary big
armed
forces that's going to come and take
over everything in the is that not the
case are they not as strong militarily
as they have been we've been told really
not
um they have made significant strides
over the last 30 years I don't mean to
belittle that but everything they're
doing in the South China Sea was
designed to intimidate Vietnam and the
Philippines into cowering and it had the
opposite effect and both countries just
ran to Japan and now have defense packs
uh it doesn't really allow the Chinese
to project power very far either they do
have a lot of ships they've got like a
650 ship Navy but 90 of them are really
small and can't sell more than 1500
kilometers from the coast
and that assumes they're going slow in a
straight line and no one's shooting at
them and actual combat conditions they
can maybe make it 600k
so it's they don't have the power
projection
and they're the country in the world
that is most dependent on reaching the
world in order to reach markets and
resources what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
space
[Music]